[Music] this year has been nothing short of
it is crazy it's like insane language but our
classmates that didn't blip had grown five
years older yeah like my little brother is
now older than me yeah it's math by the way
travel tip you should probably download a
VPN on your phone just so that the government
can't track you what we're abroad smart yeah
this big brain time I thought that you could
sense that with your Peter tingle please do
not start calling it my Peter tingle no
no I don't think I will I don't really
want to talk to negativo why because if you
don't talk to him and I have to talk I don't
want to talk to why don't you want to talk
to him get some sketches answer the phone
everywhere I go I see his face did I tell you
how my wife pretended to blip out turns out you
ran off with a guy in our hiking group we got a
fake funeral for everything a little funeral with
real I thought she was really dead do you want
to see the video he blip so technically he's 16
not 21 I'll take that she's lying I don't even
know this I had just finished my fruit cobbler
right a high school kid is dodging my calls I'm
sorry what say what again say what again I dare
you I double dare you [__] say what one more
goddamn time just a mild tranquilizer he'll be
alright don't worry it's just a bull tranquilizer
nothing to be alarmed about it's just a man
pointing a bull tranquilizer at a co-worker Sookie
you would you oh no don't look that's that's wrong
ah sorry I thought this is the bathroom
this is not what it looks like just yeah
I'm doing route leave you two alone
that's what it's no okay no if you
go ahead no I'm coming let's get a drink
I'm not 21 I'm gonna pretend you didn't
say that I'm being serious what do you want
go to the top of the Eiffel Tower with the
girl who I really like and tell her how
I feel and give her a kiss shut up man
see that wasn't so hard well-well-well how
the turntables you know they used to execute
people on this bridge they were like oh
I'm in a basket and they would drown in
the water you can't have seen me because I'm
not spider-man and also on the news it was
the night monkey the night monkey yeah
that's what it said on the news and the
news never lies alright then keep your secrets
food I know you have something to do with it
tis but a scratch a scratch your arms
off no it isn't but what's that then
just keep still what you're not dead do I
look dead hey man they will wipe anything
that moves tell me something only you would
know yeah well remember we went to Germany
you pay per view to video in your room didn't
list the titles but I could tell by the price
it was an adult film at the front desk and
you didn't know how I okay fine it's you
it's you would you stop he's too dangerous
I bet that really blows your mind I mean
yeah it's kind of great you want me to erase it
what you can do that no what should I say I am
that is an Avengers level driving hello
Charles good mother not make it he'll
call you you okay great what are you
better tell me what are you doing
cooped up in here when the weather
outside is so normal you gotta talk
I'm so confused these are confusing times
right no no I don't need sleep I need answers